[Música]
en panamá a gremios de docentes y
diversas organizaciones sociales que
impulsan protestas en contra del alto
costo de la vida se reunieron con el
gobierno de presidente de la vertido
cortizo para así buscar una salida a la
crisis que afecte el suministro de
alimentos y el combustible en ese país
las manifestaciones huelgas y cierre de
calles la habana para dos semanas en
panamá y su producción el reclamo de una
congelación del precio del combustible
la estabilización del costo de los
productos de la canasta básica y también
la verificación de elevado valor
comercial de los medicamentos en medio
de denuncias de corrupción pública y
también clientelismo por parte del
gobierno del presidente cortizo
saludamos entonces alfonso flaquea
fraguela perdón ex vicepresidente del
colegio nacional de abogados de panamá
comunicador y columnista alfonso gracias
por estar con nosotros esta mañana el
lunes en directo américa de france 24
preguntó por supuesto para un contexto
digamos general a nuestra audiencia la
situación actual en panamá un país pues
relativamente tranquilo que no está
acostumbrado digamos a este tipo de
protestas que ya
como vemos y como sabemos se va a
extender por dos semanas digamos este
está descontento social desde el día que
se disparó alfonso si efectivamente
muchas gracias raúl ya tu fin audiencia
de director panamá yo creo que perdón
directo américa yo creo que es
importante destacar aspectos importantes
a los cuales hace referencia y es
precisamente que el descontento se ha
centrado en tres aspectos fundamentales
como bien ha señalado el incremento del
combustible el incremento de los
alimentos y el incremento en los
medicamentos esto ha llevado a la
población a mantener a mantenerse en la
calle protestando desde hace
prácticamente
18 días lo cual pues ha generado y ha
obligado al gobierno nacional a tener
que sentarse con todos los los actores
que se encuentran dirigiendo estas
protestas a fin de llegar a una
conclusión de la mejor manera los
cierres de calles y avenidas se han dado
a lo largo y ancho de la república y
prácticamente presionando de esa manera
al gobierno del presidente cortizo a
sentarse a conversar y es la única
alternativa que y siento que esa ha sido
la herramienta empleada por estos
sectores para tratar de aliviar esta
profunda carga social que enfrenta
nuestro país y digamos también alfonso
que luego del congelamiento en los
precios del combustible de alguna manera
esto tampoco para situado el descontento
social conversábamos también la semana
pasada con uno de los gremios que
representan pues todas estas protestas
sociales en las calles y dice que no
todas las personas que están en
descontento están digamos representada
en esta mesa de diálogo con el gobierno
que tan cierto es esto y que porque se
deja de lado digamos a un grupo
importante como lo denunciaba la semana
pasada pues esta persona de no estar
dialogando en la mesa será también por
esta razón que todavía no terminan de
dar fin digamos a este descontento
social y estas protestas mira yo creo
que el descontento social se generó
desde que el propio presidente no
cumplió con las propuestas de campaña
que lo llevaron para que se diera la
asunción de su persona al poder y su
gabinete
evidentemente
lo que estamos enfrentando es una
desatención de esos compromisos sociales
que el presidente propuso en campaña
evidentemente se dio una pandemia en la
cual todavía estamos inmersos sin
embargo en las actuaciones que
esperábamos del gobierno nacional nunca
se dieron como bien señalaba al inicio
de la entrevista se ha desencadenado una
serie de actos de corrupción que han
sido fuertemente cuestionados donde se
dieron sobre costos en algunos productos
se dio la dimisión de un viceministro de
la presidencia sin explicación alguna al
igual que una serie de situaciones que
han generado y fueron el detonante y te
digo específicamente el pasado primero
de julio cuando el presidente de la
república anuncia que presenta su
tradicional informe a la nación
inmediatamente anuncia que se iba a
buscar una segunda opinión por una por
un padecimiento médico que actualmente
tiene y que evidentemente quedaba al
frente del vicepresidente de la
república y ministro de la presidencia
sin embargo lo que se vio a través de
las redes sociales fue una serie donde
representantes de la asamblea nacional
de diputados le gustaban el día del
anuncio del presidente le gustaban
bebidas o licores en este caso un whisky
que estaba por el orden de los 340
dólares la botella macallan número 18
sin embargo la situación generó el
descontento porque prácticamente se
estaba pagando el combustible a casi
seis dólares el galón y esta han sido
uno de los principales descontentos
comprendemos que al final
no va a poder sentarse el presidente
hablar con todos los 4 millones de
ciudadanos que vivimos en la república
de panamá pero evidentemente yo creo que
los principales temas para abordar y
tratar de que termine su gobierno de la
mejor manera ya que la falta y
prácticamente algunos meses un año y
meses deben ser el tema del alto costo
del combustible los alimentos y las
medicinas digamos por todo lo que está
diciendo alfonso más allá del costo de
la vida también es un rechazo a estos
actos de corrupción y el comportamiento
que ha tenido el ejecutivo levantino
cortizo qué tan importante ella fue que
el día ayer se haya reunido digamos el
presidente con sectores indígenas y
campesinos que mantenían bloqueada la
vía panamericana y que tan importante es
el desbloqueo de esta vía digamos para
la sana economía de panamá mira yo creo
que es un paso positivo de que el
presidente se haya tenido que haya
tenido que bajar precisamente a las
bases y hablar con el sector indígena
del país en diversos puntos del país
específicamente en san félix y ayer en
horas de la noche se firmó un acta de
entendimiento con el vicepresidente en
en santiago de veraguas y evidentemente
el objetivo principal era precisamente
levantar y abrir las vías de acceso a
nivel nacional en doble paño a fin de
que los alimentos pudieran llegar a la
repubblica a la ciudad capital y
viceversa los insumos para el área
agrícola es decir que la alimentación y
el desabastecimiento no se viera
impactada a la población lo cual me
parece un acto positivo sin embargo creo
que lo más importante de todo es que
presidente y su equipo de gobierno un
plan fielmente lo que se establece en
esos acuerdos y que el costo de los del
costo de combustible el costo de la
canasta básica al igual que el costo
referente a los medicamentos germen
porque está prácticamente por el cielo
ahora alfonso para concluir nuestra
conversación le tengo una última
pregunta y es que podemos esperar en
panamá pudiéramos esperar más protestas
o digamos que ya la cosa se está
calmando
mira yo siento que en estos momentos le
tocará al presidente de la republica
determinar hasta dónde llegará esto yo
creo que hay un acto de voluntad y de
buena disposición que la han presentado
los sectores que se han mantenido
sentados en esa mesa de negociación hay
una voluntad sin embargo en la
contraparte en este caso el gobierno
nacional deberá demostrar que hay esa
voz esa voluntad y esa disposición de
solucionar los problemas si no la hay
pues definitivamente se va a caer a un
punto muerto y evidentemente este tipo
de situación puede prolongarse claro
pues alfonso muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por ayudarnos a analizar ya
entender un poco lo que ocurre en panamá
en este momento con este descontento
estas protestas que hemos visto en los
últimos días alfonso un gran abrazo
gracias igual para ti y raúl gracias